okay hello everyone Welcome to our
second design review of today part of
the
version 14 season of design reviews and
we're looking at sound and vision and
did we did we
start on this or we've got nowhere with
this so far I think we've through most
things actually
so I think in particular for the image
stuff I'm almost maybe we want to
revisit actually now that I think about
it shorty what do you think yep yep I
think we can revisit it today as well
but it might be best for some other
development purposes to go through audio
and import export first
and then come back to image because it
might end up being a longer discussion
because we were talking last time about
image components and the question what
it actually returns and so on yes label
matrices most of those things
all right import export
uh actually Anything Audio that remains
to be discussed Carlo
I I don't think we went through them but
there shouldn't be any controversial
design either
it's just improved results
so that first one
yeah
this is there's a table of audio
hey do you know why YouTube doesn't when
it speeds up audios when it does Time
Stretch why does it not
uh adjust the pitch I mean why does it
why does it make the pitch go high
pitched
why do they not yes I I think the pitch
maintains the same
I think YouTube does like time
stretching without bit shifting
okay sometimes I do hear pitch shifting
but it's one of I agree with Carlo that
it seems like it's trying it may not
work in all cases but it's one of the
better ones we've heard anyways
okay
what's that service and how do I get to
it
that unfortunately relies on API Keys
like we have open Ai and all of that
kind of services it's similar
are we putting in the preferences
somewhere
well once we have all the other services
there it should go there but I don't
think we have do we have preferences for
enables
we do we do for for llms we have that
but we can have exactly that
thirteen three or fourteen fourteen come
okay well
I'll make sure we get our services added
do we want all services there or
anything
but I mean that's why we related for
that
well what other services do we are we
talking about here
I mean we have a bunch of service
connections right uh uh maybe not very
much used at this point apart from the
AI ones yes I think this will need to be
okay so there we go so there are things
here
now this isn't showing
the services yet but that's supposed to
be coming
yeah I'm not sure this applies exactly
to the same thing if a separate one is
be designed for these
um well hop on it because I think that's
that's becoming a
you know
I mean I agree if there is a way to have
service connections uh uh handled in a
more uh UI way that sounds good
are there new characters here
no
so what does it say voice style data
updated
uh not the dollar variable so this is
just a bit but also this is just a
back-end update uh just the OS SDK
changed and there is no design update
essentially so what happens if I say
voice style data
why on Earth is that not one of our
entities
Carlo I think this is a newer change I
reported it
a week ago or so okay yeah we can take
care of that
but you see the use case down there
which is voice style data for a
particular service like 11 labs
wow
each service right each service comes
with it's its own voices so we can query
for them and then use them what the heck
happens if I said you know voice style
Arrow moniker
and now I'm using 11 labs and they only
have Gigi
well in decades it would fail with
hopefully an informative message
um but the point is all of these are not
stored on a computer an internet request
needs to be made to figure those out
okay but what I mean like with fonts you
know we do try and fail over
to you know a font with the same
characteristics of serifs or whatever
else we don't have that font we produce
a message and then we fail over uh I'm I
think similarity of voices is not
something we can really gauge at the
moment I think we've failed we don't
substitute the voice okay but I think
that's I think with fonts we should
learn from that because you know
the gender is going to be there and the
language is going to be there yeah but
as if those information are the only
ones that we care about then yeah ever
be easy to fall back on another one that
exists right but that's my point I mean
my point is if somebody set Monica here
okay at the least with gender female
language Spanish okay if that is enough
similarity then yeah
there's a difference between fonts font
swapping is not expensive using external
Services could be costing people uh
credits and money I'm not sure if you
wanna I think I think what we want to do
is the same thing we do with fonts
produce a message and fail over to
something reasonable
okay so you want to always produce a
valid audio essentially is what you're
saying I think so with the warning uh I
think that's the right thing to do
I think it'd be super annoying if it's
like
oh no because here's the thing I I'm
using I might use you know 11 Labs or
whoever they are
you know because they are silky smooth
and lovely and so on right yep
and I just know I want to say something
in Spanish
okay I just like their way of saying it
and I didn't do it because I just wanted
Monica let's say
what I'm saying Arlo do we support
language goes to Spanish we do
and so you know if if you really don't
care about Monica you could just say
language Spanish Spanish
fair enough
yeah and we're not supported it might be
an expensive uh generating stuff with
the voice that the user did not intend
to use might be an expensive operation
right okay fine but gender is also as we
know is a little
um trickier and some Services don't even
return gender property for their voices
oh gosh
well how modern of them
yep
and how many genders do they use
the ones that do return something are
still male and female okay
I mean or at least I haven't seen
anything else no no it's good I just
like they should just say forget gender
just quote you know formant frequency
average woman of frequency high pitch
low pitch yeah yeah I mean because
that's really all it is I mean that's
the only difference here and I'm sure
that there are you know
I'm also surprised that
like I think I mean you know there's a
there's a definite mapping for child
voices and things like that
I think I mean I think it's similar to
you know just the four months move
around
right there's probably tonal differences
as well not just yeah frequencies
well okay so I don't I don't have a very
strong opinion about it I wouldn't fall
back just yet if you're okay with that
yeah it's fine
that's fine by the time they specified
Monica
let them just fail if they if Monica
isn't home okay
sounds good
uh
what's this is this is this using some
local service here
no yeah so the OS Services I'm not sure
why that is that we've mentioned that's
not making it 24. oh it's not no
and we forgot to update
okay
eventually once we get to it it is
really going to use the locals well the
operating system service it doesn't
necessarily mean local
might make a request to Apple server
better than what we have
yes
we've been working with incorporating
other neural networks but
at the moment we're at a benchmarking
stage
okay
what on Earth do you think that is
one of the specialty voices from Mac OS
it will sound bad and weird I think that
was there when I was playing with my oh
well we've got one here we've got one
here yeah
okay
okay that was there 20 years ago that
voice
I do remember it from when I was a child
okay
uh okay
by the way I assume that speak
does speak support these voices too
no
we why not
uh
it's a good question
um it uses a completely different I know
I know but I mean but it but if it's if
these are Apple voices and things it
could it could use them
I'm not even sure does this speak have
any other arguments
I don't think so right now yeah no I
don't think so
well so I think it could have a voice
argument just like this does
yeah we'll have to talk with whoever has
been in charge of that I'm assuming that
lives in the front table
I think so
did you hear that no
well I'm not sure I can set this to it's
amusing
okay
but I've now learned it's called the
trinoid not a trenoid because he said it
itself
okay what's what's new here
video formats the ones that do support
subtitles now we can
um we used to have a raw subtitles
import element but now we're adding a
slightly cooked version of that as well
you can just give it raw strings or
style strings
yeah exactly you can give it strings and
export a video with subtitles to a file
or you can import subtitles as in a
format that is more readable
what makes it more readable I mean it's
just text isn't it the raw format was
really unreadable yeah it was it was
completely a mess it was yeah if you
opened uh it was a complete disaster
MP4 should have
um some examples if you wanna open the
reference New or Old rough page
um The authoring Source notebook it's
tentative
well where do I go for that
four formats o formats yeah I'm at o but
with formats in the middle two up
uh-huh
it just beeps I'm trying to type into
this field it's just beeping
it's just beeping
well if you yeah I get that sometimes if
you click on MP4 and then then click on
that dot that you just clicked it should
work
okay
okay where do we go here
examples
well
uh keep scrolling to import elements
there are tentative examples
now if you open those two and compare
them with the following section that
says raw subtitle
I'm just totally confused here I'm sorry
I'm totally confused
to preserve the formatting using text
and style
and style is style comma White
and that evidently doesn't display
ideally
oh did we talk to front end Carlo about
that no I was trying to talk to John
about this as well in tomorrow's meeting
okay I'm totally confused subtitles text
is this raw subtitle it says raw here is
that what you mean or is that not what
you mean that was uh that was a copy
paste typo the raw subtitles is the next
section that is not tentative we've had
that before so if you want to see
how stuff are stored in the file it's
kind of a script info then the format of
how stuff are stored in the in the file
I just don't know get rid of the data is
this what we're talking about here yes
as you can see that is completely on
well it's very annoying to parse
yeah I get it I get it okay all right so
then but then there's some tagging
information here which you are then
losing I see in subtitle textures well
we are not necessarily losing it in
normal in the subtitle element all of
that information is preserved by style
and text
um so I understand the subtitle element
but in the subtitle text elements yeah
that is blowing all this stuff away if
you're just saying a haircut please
correct
that sounds sensible to me yep
okay
I mean this is obviously important and
the thing we've discussed many times
which I really want to see an example of
is natural spreadsheet understanding
and you know we've discussed using llm
type technology for this
which
Sean seemed to think was not going to be
necessary but I'd like to see proof of
that
yeah and and I think the last discussion
between you and Sean
um you said you'll suggest a developer
for that
I thought you guys were dealing with
that I thought I did suggest something
is it is it are you waiting for me
um if you're waiting for me you better
you better tell somebody that because as
far as I'm concerned if nobody tells me
anything based on one of these meetings
if nobody gives me any reminder and it's
just left to me to remember what to do
it's not going to happen
okay what is the status of that probably
then
um probably then it was never relate to
you
um I can send you so you're giving me
homework then I'll send you an email
though yes
I don't really like that I thought we
discussed it in much more detail in that
meeting
course of action
right no no no
I gave you a specific I gave you
specific information there
but you didn't follow up or what
I I think really what was discussed was
that the project
that there are other projects Sean was
working on and we we just
I think okay so probably this is what
happened what I recall is that this was
probably right before or around summer
school and we were thinking we could get
someone from summer school
and then I got into fortino and didn't
remember to follow up with that well
please follow up sure I mean
I don't think I mean I
yeah
let's please follow up I don't want this
dropped I was told I said there's a
course of action that involves using
machine learning okay
I was told oh you shouldn't do that
Sean Etc or figure it out without that
I said show me that you can
so I don't want to hear it didn't get it
got dropped because if it got dropped
let's go to the default that I thought
should be pursued okay
okay
I have no idea whether this makes sense
I have no idea how elaborate is the
format
uh it's very much used by the our
community I'm aware of that I know that
how elaborate is the format is it a very
complicated format or is it a fairly
simple format is it like CSV or is it
something with with endless tentacles
um it's on unfortunately very under
documented both the format and the
library I just committed something I
thought earlier today
um
my nice person here
so I mean what what are you telling me
is it I mean so I think obviously we're
using you know we have some data files
in our format can we say okay great we
can import them or does it have
footnotes 10 feet long
no I think we can just import that we're
talking about numerical data string data
Boolean
um and all of those will just come in as
tables of data
okay in the appropriate formats types
sounds good
what is this
docx the Microsoft Word For What the
format is but what do we change about it
um it's not supported in our system yet
at all
we're talking about Dockers but not docx
is
useful I actually am supportive but for
like 20 years
I don't see it
really
well anyway I thought it was
shows how often I've used it
maybe I've exported from
dot to something else anyway okay
well that sounds good so similar to the
support for PDF you're saying here
right except that I I don't think we
have a renderer to bring stuff in as
page images but we'll first attempt
we'll have text maybe format text and
embedded images
and then we'll see where we can take it
from there
sounds good
okay what should I be looking at here I
mean I I don't know what I'm looking at
there are no examples examples all that
but really as you're seeing types of
data supported Boolean dates integers
real string time stamps and so forth so
we'll just get tables of those
what is the timestamp it's just a date
object I I haven't figured that out yet
um it was kind of an unfortunate
situation the developer left and now we
gave it to another developer
dates and time dates and time stamps are
done separately in our data I don't yet
know yeah most systems separate
most systems have three kinds of things
there's date time and date time
our date is date time
yeah unless you use granularity in which
case
right
fair enough okay let's see is there
other stuff we should go over right now
today back up to image components image
component detect
all right from last time
image components you can take a look at
that probably has the biggest change
you know what my mouse froze I thought
this might happen
I'm telling you my mouse is is ill
is to rejuvenate it
I don't know I think I just I think it
was some update to the mouse driver
okay
okay so we talked about this and we said
we didn't really like that very much and
where was the thing that we talked about
image contents as as the way to do this
what what happened I have I have updates
in image contents as well everything
that's marked candidate up on the page
is new since last week
okay so up in the syntax box as well
you suggested adding properties and then
I was looking at component measurements
there we have criteria and format and
things like that
there is one one problem with Criterion
and component selection uh with more
elaborate segmentation methods that
segmentation itself is costly
so we can still support Criterion and
then have people do the segmentation
every time and then pick their segments
but the more reasonable workflow is for
people to compute the segmentation save
it as the label Matrix and then work
with select components component
measurements and all of that
for any other analysis well why don't
you just do it for them
just cash cash all the results and then
oh no no I mean just do if they say give
me it with a Criterion
we compute all the components and then
do exactly what you said use component
measurements and so on and compute you
know apply the criteria that's what this
design this tentative design is
suggesting all I'm saying is that a lot
of the times it makes more sense for
people to save their results and then do
additional computations on on that label
Matrix because it's expensive together
because they want to you want to try
multiple criteria and this is only a
line one criteria to be tried at a time
mm-hmm
well I mean you know Roger I would say
the thing we were discussing in the last
meeting where we're talking about in the
last meeting shoddy we were talking
about
um cases where symbolic computation is
slow but numeric compensation is fast
and we imagine what we're going to do
you know up to two seconds of trying to
do it symbolically and if that doesn't
work we're going to fall back to
numerical what I was suggesting was that
we have a progress monitor that says
you're trying symbolic computation you
know reverting to numerical or something
or falling back to numerical in two
seconds 1.5 seconds one second blah blah
blah and I could imagine here if there's
an expensive operation that takes a
visibly long amount of time that we
bring up a progress monitor that simply
says you know Computing whatever they
are component whatever it is why is that
useful it's useful because it tells
people that's an expensive operation and
if in the
progress monitor that it brings up it
says what the function is that just
directly does that people will be able
to figure out oh I need to do this
multiple times let me do that expensive
part just once
that makes sense Roger does that make
sense to you also and I think it's a
good design approach I think you know
the thing we invented there seems like a
good General General thing to do
yeah probably
I mean it kind of relates to a little
bit
um
yeah no okay let's go down that path I
think that's it's probably gonna image
components already since last week it
already it already had a progress
monitor what Mark has added since last
week is a stop button similar to net
train you'll just get an intermediate
result
that's cool
I think we need to look at this I mean
one more time and you know when you when
this has all come to equilibrium unless
unless you think the image stuff is now
at equilibrium
what do we what do we have here that we
can cover right now
I think these are all the probably all
of these image components and how stuff
gets integrated to image contents is the
real remaining thing here
okay but it's not super quick probably
fine all right so let's pick that up
again are you overall happy with what
you see on this page so that we proceed
with
image components I think so I mean okay
particularly and you haven't listed
image contents yeah
um you can open image no I understand
you haven't listed it here right so but
you did change yeah yes the agenda we
haven't updated
we should
I don't see any kind of stuff scroll
down
mask bounding box and masked image
I don't quite understand why that's not
the default or or maybe in the in the um
in the the and this here
I'm confused by why that's another folks
here
in image contents be the default in
image contents
yeah I mean well I don't know I don't
know
um
I you have to warm me up on this again I
I
you know I've forgotten some of the
details of this but I I thought what we
had what we were concluding was that we
have this new method for doing image
components
and that the whole point is you want to
get the zebras right I want to get out
of this picture I just want to get a
bunch of masked zebras which could be
many things I mean by mosque zebras I
mean zebras whose image area is is
masked off
right
um
anyway sorry I'm now having an image of
you know like those blind the things
that they have for horses to keep them
from getting distracted and anyway never
mind
okay sorry the the focus okay so you
understand what I'm saying that that
would be
that was what I understood was one of
the things that could come out you know
I want a list I've got a picture show me
all the zebras in the picture just like
with facial features can easily get the
images of the faces in the picture that
that is in image cases that's already
the image cases function image contents
is this one that Returns the data set
okay but so what and I think there is
what was the change it's a new
segmenting anything
uh
you know it's a new back end which
allows for some new functionality is
that correct yes okay what is the new
functionality
the the the one bigger function we're
proposing is that image components
function itself which returns a label
Matrix a full segmentation okay but what
is the new thing that image contents can
do
um I don't know why I can try this in
um prototype build but um like image
cases image comma mask image should
actually give you the masked out zebras
and elephants in that image
and then same thing with image
components if you ask for masked image
as a property it will include that in
the data set
okay so you're saying if I take this
picture here
okay and I say image
what do I what what should I do if I
take cases of this
and now I say what the heck all these
things
animals I mean let's just say zebras
here so what do I do I say zebras but by
default you'll get all of the animals or
all of all of the objects in the image
well I got enough I think you should say
zebra singular well I think I should say
control equals zebra
that that'll work
I hope that works
great
well maybe it's a different kind of
zebra I don't know it's that is a
problem we I think still have to go back
to Mountain zebra
do you see a concept
entity no no I don't I don't believe in
concept entities but I don't see one
anyway
foreign
but you don't even need to specify that
second argument so this second argument
problem we'll have to solve but
regardless of that it gives you these
zebras then
elephants those are garbage for what
happened here
I don't know what happened I'll report
that is this this is what it's always
been doing is that correct no it it
shows a nice looking concept entity
yes has been doing that forever yes yes
yes
okay but if I say masked image here
it'll do something different is that
right
it will give you the same images with
Alpha channel that backgrounds is our
masks okay so how do I do that comma
watt here
uh masked image
I doubt but that's right because that's
asking for a masked image zebra isn't it
it's got to be automatic or all or
something there I don't understand this
argument I I think we uh we
automatically understand whether an
entity is given or a class is given or a
property it's not a valid object I gotta
go so let's sort this out and we'll come
back yeah as I said I think this wasn't
a prototype but yeah
okay all right
so one one more restoration on this not
for very long let's try and combine it
Roger we should be able to have some
kind of uh you know
pick up meeting with a bunch of these
different items in it yeah I just don't
want to do it too quick because then we
don't resolve them anyway so yeah that's
probably first couple of days next week
or something like that then I think it's
fine yep okay sounds good sounds good
okay thanks a lot guys